it's not meaning you'd be afraid of it's
the other guy
and he wants out
[Music]
claims he made a deal with the devil
wishes notice you know the rationalists
didn't he wants to agree but this coal
on fire presents a pretty compelling
argument for hail Satan
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything or relating to the
MCU Ghost Rider is on his way to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's been
confirmed by several different sources
at this point and everybody is really
excited to see him and see him interact
with the other MCU characters and it
seems like Ghost Rider is going to be
coming very soon and not only one Ghost
Rider but three ghost riders according
to a recent report so I'll break down
all the new Ghost Rider reports in this
video and then we're gonna talk about
how Ghost Rider is going to enter the
Marvel Cinematic Universe if you're new
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a Wolverine Funko pop to
enter all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and leave a
comment about the video down below now
prior to this Marvel has given us a
little taste of Ghost Rider in the past
we have the two Nicolas Cage Ghost Rider
films that weren't received all that
well but still some fans liked them and
then we have Gabriel Lunas Ghost Rider
that appeared in Marvel's agents of
shield now this wasn't your traditional
Ghost Rider this was Robbie Reyes who
drove a Dodge Charger powered by
Hellfire instead of the traditional
motorcycle however he was still very
well received by fans and was perhaps
the biggest guest superhero on agents of
shield and went on to play a very
valuable role in season 4 and would go
on to become a very significant allied
to shield
Gabriel Luna and Ghost Rider would end
up leaving the show however shortly
after it was announced that Gabriel Luna
would reprise his role as Ghost Rider in
a hulu series now unfortunately not too
long ago this was cancelled but I'll
explain why this is actually a really
really good thing and how it leads to
Ghost Rider entering the MCU let's start
off with our first report and this is
coming from the direct calm and they say
according to their contributing insider
Daniel Richmond or Daniel rpk as some
people may know him according to him a
Ghost Rider project is being developed
by
Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios this
project will be set up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the titular
character will not be the version
portrayed by Gabriel Luna it is
currently uncertain if the ghostwriter
project is a feature film or live-action
series so according to this report Ghost
Rider is making his way to the MCU but
it's not going to be Gabriel Lunas
Robbie Reyes Ghost Rider
it's most likely going to be Johnny
Blaze and he'll most likely make his
appearance and phase for now rumor has
it that the ghost riders show that was
supposed to come to Hulu starring
Gabriel Luna as Robbie Reyes was
cancelled because Kevin Feige actually
wants to use Ghost Rider in the MCU
now Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios was recently named the chief
creative officer over Marvel in its
entirety and that includes comics movies
and TV shows that's why he's leading all
of the Disney plush shows so him
shutting down the Hulu Ghost Rider
series so he could use Ghost Rider in
the MCU makes a ton of sense but it
looks like he could possibly have bigger
plans for Ghost Rider than we expected
because according to another report
we're not going to get one Ghost Rider
in the MCU we're going to get three
according to the Twitter account Rodger
Wardell who is the same person that
leaked all of the information about
Avengers endgame all of which came true
says that don't worry
not only one but three versions of the
Ghost Rider are coming Doctor Strange 2
will lead to midnight Suns nightmare is
not a villain of the movie so not one
but three ghost riders so really
exciting news but now the question is
how exactly are there going to be three
ghost riders in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and how exactly are they going
to enter the MCU there are a couple of
projects in which we can assume Ghost
Rider will most likely pop up in and it
seems like we pretty much already know
who the three ghost riders are going to
be we're going to get Johnny Blaze most
likely a female version of Ghost Rider
and most likely Johnny blazes brother
Danny ketch but more on that in just a
bit since we already got two Ghost Rider
movies in the past with Nicolas Cage and
since agents of shield had Ghost Rider
on it he more than likely won't get a
movie at first he'll more than likely
appear in another project and the two
projects that he's most likely to appear
in are the Wanda vision series and
dr. strange in the multiverse of madness
especially if there are indeed going to
be three different versions of Ghost
Rider one division could be the perfect
place to introduce Ghost Rider we know
that in this series Wanda is actually
going to be referred to for the very
first time in the MCU as the Scarlet
Witch we also know that Agatha Harkness
is going to indeed be in the show as
well and it's going to explore the Salem
witch trials so this show is really
going to dive into the more mystic
magical side of the MCU it's also been
rumored that one division is going to
introduce the Darkhold and this book is
created in the hell realm and the hell
realm of course is where Mephisto is and
who gives Ghost Rider
Johnny blazes Ghost Rider his powers
that would be Mephisto so there are a
ton of connections that could be made in
the Wan division series with Johnny
Blaze but if we're talking about three
ghost riders multiple versions of ghost
riders we know that Wanda is going to be
creating multiple realities we saw a few
different realities in that quick little
teaser that Marvel gave us at the Super
Bowl but that's when everything is still
okay and happy-go-lucky we haven't seen
any of the darker parts of it like
Agatha Harkness and the Salem witch
trials but those darker realities are
where they could introduce these
different versions of Ghost Rider
especially if Mephisto is going to be
involved with the project but then we
have Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness which is where we're most likely
going to be getting these three
different versions if not the
introduction that will lead to the three
versions being in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
now Doctor Strange - is said to dip into
the Gothic and the horror and the
horrific originally scott derrickson was
going to direct the film and he said
that it's going to be the MCS first
horror film however due to him wanting
it to be a true horror film and Kevin
Feige not wanting that he's no longer
directing the film but they did bring in
another former Marvel director and
current horror film director Sam Raimi
so we know it's still going to have the
horror type of vibe which would be
perfect to introduce Ghost Rider we also
know that Doctor Strange deals a lot
with demons and demons are a pretty big
part of Ghost Rider in fact one of the
differences between Johnny Blaze and his
brother Danny ketch is that they're
bonded to a different demon
and one of the biggest difference
between the ghostwriters is that Danny
ketch and the demon actually share
control of Ghost Rider and he develops
blue fire instead of red fire and then
we have Alejandra Jones who is a female
version of Ghost Rider in the comics
Alejandra Jones is training in a temple
for the sole purpose to take the place
of Johnny Blaze as a ghost writer Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
since it's going to involve the
multiverse and many different universes
would be the perfect opportunity to
introduce all three different versions
at one time because although the leak
says that there's going to be three
ghost riders in the MCU there's really
only going to be one main one moving
forward once they're all introduced so
in the movie the most likely introduced
Johnny Blaze as the main ghost riders
but while we're dealing with different
realities will most likely see Alejandra
Jones and then Danny ketch as well and
perhaps they could even keep Danny ketch
alongside of Johnny Blaze because it
seems like Marvel has some pretty big
plans for Ghost Rider because as the
report says Doctor Strange too will lead
to the midnight sons now if you caught a
few of my videos on the midnight sun's
and the monster verse that Marvel is
kind of setting up you know that Marvel
is heading in a kind of particular
direction with some of their characters
one division Doctor Strange - and blade
are going to explore more of the darker
side of the Marvel Universe
and according to the reports that next
team of the dark side of the Marvel
Universe is going to be the midnight
Suns in the comics this team consists of
Doctor Strange
Johnny blazes Ghost Rider along with
Danny catches Ghost Rider
blade and Morbius and it seems like this
could be the team in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as well we know that
Morbius kind of exists in the same
universe that spider-man Tom Hollands
spider-man in the MCU exists so it is
possible that their plan could be to
bring Morbius over from the SPU mc2 the
MCU to be a part of the midnight sons
not to mention that Moon Knight has also
been a part of the midnight sons team as
well and we know that we're getting a
moon night Disney Plus show relatively
soon and Elsa bloodstone has also been a
part of the team and Elsa bloodstone has
been reported to be entering the MCU
somewhat soon and perhaps the midnight
sons could be where she's going to make
that MCU debut of hers
now of course there is the possibility
that ghostwriter could get his very own
at Disney Plus show this would come
after his Marvel introduction in 1
division or Doctor Strange too because
Ghost Rider isn't going to take the
spotlight from Wanda or vision in the
Wanda vision series or from Doctor
Strange in multiverse of madness he's
just going to be introduced and be a
part of the story
it'll just be his introduction but
Marvel isn't going to have Ghost Rider
entered the MCU just for a quick little
cameo especially if Kevin Feige really
did cancel the Ghost Rider Hulu series
so he could use them in the MCU so it
does seem like ghost riders going to
play a pretty important role in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
moving forward and we could be seeing
him as early on as phase 4 in the 1
division series or in Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness but let me
know which one of these you'd like to
see him make his MCU debut in let me
know which one you prefer in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to
Ghost Rider and the MCU for live updates
you can follow me on Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof